the jurogan experience gentlemen
anyway yes sir we're in texas always
great to be here with you
yeah and uh another another mover
you're a mover here as well uh yep uh
spent uh last month with his parents
looking for a house and i think we've
found a nice house to move into in
spring texas what pushed you over the
edge
um all the [ __ ] going on in
california
the laws the restrictions the taxes 13.3
percent
uh the governor the mayor uh the
congressman
the senators is that enough yes
okay good i second to all that that's
what that's exactly as as a doctor
right when you look at the lockdowns
like this
is this is where it gets really
controversial right because people are
saying that the whole reason for doing
this is to protect people because the
emergency rooms are overcrowded
and uh you don't think that's a suitable
no i i think restrictions of our rights
is a key
issue there i you know in looking
contrasting what has been going on in
texas outside of austin but in houston
and other places
they're reasonable abbott has been very
reasonable about
certain factors that i love we're a law
abiding
state okay we believe in individual
rights
california is the opposite yeah how can
you live
pleasantly regardless of what occupation
you're in how can you live there
understanding that every movement that
you're doing is under surveillance
cops are coming to your house during
thanksgiving or is that happening though
i didn't i know i don't know
something happened in canada it was a
really disturbing thing did you see it
i didn't see in canada they came in like
full [ __ ] gestapo mode
and just a family yeah they had five
people in the house or something like
that and people ratted them out
like it's just as soon as you make
something a law
and then you send cops out to enforce
that and the cops think they're
justified and you get
a few dumb cops and then they do
something like this
it just lets everybody know like oh this
is why it's dangerous to have too many
restrictions
because then you have people that have
to enforce those restrictions right and
they're not doing their job i mean the
sheriff and the head of police in in
california or in los angeles came out
and said they wouldn't
upheld uphold the uh restrictions that
newsom was putting in i think in san
francisco also because it won't take
them away from
orange county it would take them away
from their ability to do the real work
protecting the citizens not arresting
them
yeah it's you know what happened in
staten island is just
mind-boggling with that restaurateur was
arrested and given a ten thousand dollar
a day
fine for having his restaurant open he
was social distant he had the
shields and protection everyone was
wearing a mask
but because they had locked down staten
island so tightly
you know they're devastating all the
businesses there but he went up against
it
it just seems to me that the amount of
money that it would have cost
to open up new icu rooms
and and figure out a way to staff them
would have been far less than the amount
of money that it's
costing all these people to lose their
businesses
all these people to stop working right
it just seems
rational that like the amount of money
you could have figured out a way to tax
people
like say hey we're gonna let everybody
open up but we need a temporary tax
on sales of whatever that'll just go
to help this and people probably would
have said okay well it'll just keep
and give people the opportunity like you
you have your options
you have your rights you can choose to
go to work
choose to go to these restaurants choose
to go to these bars and
we'll figure out some way to what open
up new york city doing something like
that
i don't know i think i think they were
doing some uh in restaurants they were
adding a small amount of additional
tax to compensate for the covid
uh did they shut down indoor dining yeah
and then
yeah at least they have outdoor dining
which is hilarious
new york has it and it's [ __ ]
freezing and snowing l.a
doesn't have it and then the woman who
votes it's one woman
who decides to shut everything down goes
to dinner
outside the day she does it and lied
and said the reason why she was doing it
is because her favorite restaurant and
she wanted to say
she was sorry to the staff and apologize
for what they had to do
didn't talk to anybody there full-on lie
right the people who worked there going
she didn't talk to us
yeah this is not just rules rules don't
count for them yeah it's just i get that
people want to stay safe
but as a doctor does this make sense to
you like what
no and uh you know on my list i have a
couple of the um
uh the articles it doesn't make sense
when you look at california
in the repetitive manner in which they
put a lock down
we should see if it's effective the
numbers of cases dropping but they're
not they're going up so what does it
tell us it tells us that the masks
aren't working
the six feet of separation is not
working
there's some other element that's out
there that's creating
you know negating all the protective
modalities that they're doing
so why lock down you know the state
allow people to have their their
employment but
aren't check me if i'm wrong
but is having cases gone down over the
last two weeks
since everything's been completely
locked up no they've been
one day they went up i know and i saw
that yesterday despite newsom said
there's going to be a surge on top of a
surge they're waiting for it and they're
talking about
right because he's uh a doctor
he's the grand public that's it are they
using the pcr test
to validate that that's a huge question
they're using the pcr test
and they're using the rapid one but you
know they're not as
they're not accurate they're not
accurate they're just something we have
now to utilize and then put a lot of
credibility on it
the difference between the different pcr
testing is that
so there's a spike around christmas time
which is supposedly
due to what is the idea that it's due to
gatherings is it
says because they were trying to say
that it was related to
uh thanksgiving so between october
november end of november but if you look
at it
it seems like two weeks after the end of
november that would make sense right
that would be right around show me you
like
yeah well that's that's longer than two
weeks
right because it seems like it kicked in
the spikes kicked in right around
uh what is the big first big spike right
there what is that the 16
well that's kind of two weeks that's two
weeks ish
i would want to know what cycles they're
testing on if there's any changes of the
pcr test
i believe this is hospitalization so
right or is this new cases there's new
cases
yeah it's uh look
it's not good but you know um someone
pointed out that the cdc website has
finally uh got information on it about
vitamin d
and and some other things right they
just put it on there just in december
which is like jesus guys nine months
into a [ __ ] pandemic
and you just started putting things on
about vitamins and the importance of
nutrition
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background by using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience